we're trying to solve for here is X so 2
to the X plus 3 equals 4 times 3 to the
X so how do we get that variable X by
itself well you have to decide do we
want to take the log base 2 of both
sides or do we want to take the log base
3 of both sides in either case you want
to do the same thing to both sides to
keep the equation balanced but I think
what I'm going to do here is I'm going
to take the log base 2 of both sides so
let's go ahead and do that so we've got
log base 2 of 2 to the X plus 3 equals
log base 2 of 4 times 3 to the X ok so
you're with me so far we did it to both
sides we're keeping the equation
balanced but the log base 2 and the
exponential function base 2 those are
inverses so they cancel one another out
and we're just left with X plus 3 so
we've eliminated one log ok and we've
eliminated one exponential equation ok
but we still have this group here to
work with so what we're gonna do now is
because these are multiplied together
the 4 and the 3 to the X we're going to
use the properties of logs to expand
this so this is going to be log base 2
of 4 plus log base 2 of 3 to the X power
ok now we're going to continue on we're
going to take this exponent use the
power rule for logs you're gonna bring
that down in front of the log ok 4 is
really like 2 squared ok so log base 2
an exponential base 2 those cancel those
are inverses so we're left with 2 over
here we have X log base 2 of 3 okay and
X plus 3 okay so we're getting closer we
want to group the X terms on one side we
want to get everything else on the other
side so what we're gonna do is we're
going to subtract this X log base 2 of 3
so that's going to be X minus X log base
2 of 3 equals 2 and I'm going to move
the 3 over here by subtracting 3 from
both sides that's negative 1 okay now
what we're going to do because we want
to get the X by itself we're going to
factor it out of both of these terms so
we're going to factor out the ax which
leaves us with 1 minus log base 2 of 3
ok equals negative 1 and now all we have
to do is divide by this proportion here
that we don't need
okay and don't want both sides keep it
balanced one minus log base two of three
these are going to cancel and you can
see x equals this quantity here so this
is a calculator already answer you can
go ahead and put it in your calculator
to get a decimal approximation but this
is exact so I hope this example problem
gave you a better understanding about
how to work with logs
especially when you have different bases
okay like we have base three and base
two if you're enjoying these videos
subscribe to the channel go ahead and
check out some of my past videos on logs
and some of my other videos as well and
I look forward to seeing you in the next
video I'll talk to you soon